what if I told you this was last Monday
morning in your life so I met a late
afternoon late workout today I'm good to
have the unrolling on that blue thing
anyway something really good happen what
I'm not lying I'm recording daily B
Jordan got something really good that
excited me you know I can't do doing
some good happen if she she's some
humble pie he just asked me how long was
the video 40-minute it just asked me if
the video was too long it couldn't be
too long to said no because of the
contents good enough he was talking
about a perfect chin up video and how it
didn't hit im sue some short and started
working with me we said social media
game has dramatically improved if you
can imagine just like my muscles have
improved and is back anyway he said some
really good success amplifying videos
it's like a hundred bucks that's what
this one was right and have a drink
hundred bucks but I mean mine was media
went from like no no it's awesome to
highlight to tell them how you lost this
book so episode I like you know I'm just
sticking back to two or three videos
that I've made I like talking about the
videos that I knew were going to be big
got it but sometimes they're not going
even though I thought they're gonna
maybe that's what happened to you yeah
so that's what's happening to you guys
all the time and so I get in so this is
a perfect you know it's like raining
outside page which I love to play videos
they had a lot of ethics happened a
bunch of them got sad because they were
thinking about their two cents while
remaking three from yesterday like it's
a grind like this
this isn't 365 days of glory like you
know so it's a little off Thursday just
like felicitously like sitting here you
just like ponderings like
why didn't that happen it was a very
good video is one of my best videos no
no you said it was your best for like
the best video ever made but the market
gets assigned not you Jordan hunt Thank
You that a lot but I learned so that's
it long from your losses everybody
that's the way there so anyway just
thought it was a really interesting way
to I need today what I'm going to be a
big episode so I'm sitting here just
just literally just called the rock I
was okay put some together I'm going to
make a 1 second video we'll just do a
mash-up and then I was just thinking
about what Jordan said it so you know
what wait a minute this is exactly what
we should be doing today which is you
know the 365 day world truth is the
majority days or losses you know the
majority of days it's not going exactly
as you want it and I think you do one
from it
I do you think that a perfect chin-up
video is fairly neat and that's why
maybe 40 targets wrong room
yeah you know I don't know anyway it's a
nice to mom
giving me it's a cop